e
e e
one um I'm going to go ahead and get the
hearing started um before we
do uh if you could lead us in the Pledge
of Allegiance
please to the flag the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all oh and
there I I was just about to say that I
hadn't spoken to will to find out if he
was going to um be on time and now I
know that he is um so first order of
business is we have a a public hearing
scheduled on on a non- gerine
Amendment um and and we we've discussed
this um when this was part of the house
bill that this was something we were
keeping in our pocket that if the Senate
version of the bill didn't come over
that we had a meth mechanism to work on
this um the underlying bill is a
unemployment related bill um but not
close enough that we could simply attach
an amendment but if we hold a public
hearing on the amendment then um it it
becomes Germain so with that uh
representative McKenzie if you could
introduce this
amendment
and um I guess we don't
have that
folder all right
start good morning and U for the record
my name is Mark McKenzie I represent
Hillsboro District
40 uh and I'm here this morning uh to
introduce this amendment and to uh ask
the for the committee
support the amendment is not unfamiliar
to this committee it had been brought up
before so I I don't think we have to uh
spend a whole lot of time but let me say
that it does uh the benefit of this
particular piece is that
preserves uh the framework of the
various steps of the unemployment
system it adds to that uh uh some top
steps to increase the rate so it go
because currently it's left at $41,500
which is a top rate uh the average uh
unemployment benefit in New Hampshire if
I recall is about 350 some odd dollars a
week so what this does is it it uh it
basically puts that uh additional steps
at the top and there's a strategy for
for doing that because what it does is
it it at least brings it up to the
survivable um uh number the number that
you need to actually survive within uh
the state of New Hampshire it should be
much higher than it
is this is this amendment is a little
bit differently yeah so it brings it up
to
60,000 uh the other thing it does is to
provide consistency across the scale so
the way that the system was was working
and works now is that the bottom end uh
replacement wage was around
58% so what happens uh as you move up
the scale is that the uh the
relationship between the replacement
rate uh and the benefit it starts to
deteriorate to the point where uh where
can be as low as probably 30% uh
replacement wages so what I Tred to do
on the scale is to is to preserve the
scale to level it across the across the
entire board uh because there's no real
reason why somebody who who is at the
lower end of scale uh is paid
differently in terms of the
ratio uh and I think you know I this is
and you inuy commissioner lers is here
uh this is somewhat frustrating in the
sense that this has been many many years
the last time the unemployment rate was
raised uh representative infantine was a
young man uh many many years ago and uh
and so we have not raised this rate for
years now if you consider that the
Unemployment uh
legislation is connected and was born as
part of the Social Security
act if we had told people receiving
Social Security in the room downstairs
that big chamber you're not going to
receive any increase in your your Social
Security rate for 25 years to be held to
pay so why is it that we take unemployed
workers and we don't we don't treat them
the same we don't keep the schedule
current we don't we don't make sure that
the replacement wage uh is survivable I
think it's uh I think it's a big Miss in
terms of uh of you know of the uh of the
legislature not to move this thing
forward so I I asked for this you can
get the numbers um the numbers are a
little bit more expensive uh over the
course of the years uh then was a how
the Senate bill I think the Senate bill
and you'll hear the numbers and we heard
in the subcommittee I think the Senate
bill was maybe 28 to 30 million uh and
this one's a little bit more than that
this spreads it out over three years now
some people say why would do that cuz in
the end it's the same but I was trying
to be responsive to those people who
were uh I had heard early on that the
people wanted to kind of bring that on
board over a period of time so I try to
be uh try to address that as well um but
also let me say that the the trust fund
you can hear this from the Deputy
Commissioner I've been doing this aair
of my a little while I was on the
unemployment uh advisory committee for
many years uh in my position with the
aflci this is the most money we've ever
had as far as I know in the trust fund
there's over 400 million in the trust
fund currently 104 million of which came
from the cares act which is a direct
contribution from the cares act into the
fund and what that did essentially was
to was to take that money and accelerate
uh for the employers uh how they' got
the discount that much sooner so it was
a benefit certainly to the
employers um who by the way have the
third lowest uh uh tax rate in the
country uh so you got a fund that's got
400 million in it you've got the lowest
tax rate in the country you have one of
the lowest unemployment rates in the
country this is a time to do this this
is clearly a time to do this and and
this is a catch-up bill and I hope if we
can pass this bill and we can move
forward that we don't spent many many
years was 2007 I think it's the last
time we did this we don't take all of
that time to try try to bring this this
thing up this is about fness and about
equity and I'll end with this I've
worked on a number of uh layoffs big
layoffs I remember getting the call from
uh uh Governor Shaheen at the time who
told me that the Berlin paper mill was
going to close and it was not as it was
not a gentle end it was a very abrupt
closure of the of the Berlin paper mill
now Berlin New Hampshire those of you
who have been up there that's kind of a
world on its
own so when 3 4,000 people were laid off
unemployment was the only Lifeline they
had the only thing that kept them from
absolute poverty was the unemployment
legislation and I work with those people
for years we set up a whole operation up
there and the stories that we heard from
people were incredible had this bill not
been in
place it would have been it would have
that Community would have been destroyed
let's bring this up to where it should
be so that when that safety net is
needed when we cast that net that it
catches people in a place in their lives
and supports them until I can get
through this uh through this problem uh
and get back to work and keep in mind
that for the most part we only people
only unemployment of less than 10 weeks
in the state of New Hampshire so I ask
the committee to stake this position out
as a house position and I'm here to
answer any questions you might have
relative to that thank you Mr chairman
all right thank you very much are there
questions representative infant time
thank you so I apologize I haven't been
around the last couple weeks um but I
was reviewing some emails over the
weekend and one of the things that had
never occurred to me when we were
discussing this legislation
um was the fact that Municipal and state
employers do not contribute and do not
pay unemployment they are required to um
pay back right all right so if someone
gets uh someone goes on unemployment in
the state or any of our towns and
they're out for 3 months on unemployment
they have to pay dollar for dollar back
to the unemployment never occurred to me
that that would be the issue that the
Senate was grappling
with what is what is
your your feeling there because because
again we I don't think any of us ever
thought about it when we were having our
discussions and that seems to be the
problem that the senate had with it well
I think you'll hear uh from the deputy
if if you're going to have him come up
here it's a fairly low number because we
talked about this in the committee uh
and I think the number comes in at about
over over 100,000
uh I think it was 110 some OD thousand
but the deputy commission can uh bring
us up to speed on that so it it is a um
you know potentially could be uh an
increase and I don't know what the
unemployment rate is within the public
sector um but this is this is in in in
the scheme of things it's a much smaller
group of people than would be the
general uh group that we're trying to
cover right now I think there's about I
don't last time I looked at probably
7500 or so people on unemployment I
don't know how many people from the
public sector very probably a fairly
small number and we have the number that
we do have a query that was done by the
department relative to that thank
you representative
to follow up on what chairman
infantine said I believe it's not just
municipalities but it's also nonprofit
organizations are
payback as well so they don't pay in
they have the option to but they don't
they do the payback dollar for
dollar and we have the low third lowest
rate in the United States so it's a very
low rate for employeers they've got
every they have every uh discount that
they can get because the fund is hit the
400 million Mark um so this bill will
not change that at all will not increase
their rate it won't take the discount
away from uh from them
uh because the way that the system is
structured the way the discounts were
applied so I I think this is a I think
this is a good time to do this I really
do some point we got to do it further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you um I have a card from
David juv who is opposed to this
amendment he represents be
Mr juvet how many days left
sir um before you hit that beautiful
Oasis of Arizona well Mr chair I I
normally wouldn't have started my
testimony with this but since you asked
it's 5 months 17 days 6 hours 10 minutes
and 48
seconds well well deserved I'm I'm glad
to see you here at least maybe one final
time in front of Labor thank you um for
the record my name is Dave Juan I'm a
senior vice president uh for public
policy with the business and industry
Association we represent employers I
need to give what I would call nuanced
testimony for those of you that recall
when uh represent McKenzie's bill was
initially heard in this committee we did
not oppose that bill we did not testify
in support but we did not oppose it
because I think as an organization we
agree that there needs to be some of
valuation um
over adjusting the uh weekly
unemployment benefit amounts it's been
uh well over 10 years maybe as possibly
as long as 15 years since that's taken
place um we had some qualms over the
language because we felt that it might
be taking maybe a little too aggressive
an approach that could impact the
balance of the trust fund especially if
there's an economic
downturn and if there were a severe
recession it would it would likely
bankrupt the trust fund and we would
have to borrow from the federal
government either of those cases would
result uh most certainly in higher
employment uh taxes higher employer
unemployment
taxes the Senate also had a bill Senate
Bill
436 and we were quite involved in that
and I thought we would be involved in
that the same way we would be involved
in representative McKenzie's bill which
was that's the initial proposal all the
stakeholders get together we Hammer
something out that everybody can live
with that's not what happened in the
house and and the bill was tabled and
there it sat the Senate bill Senate 436
uh Senator Perkins quook was the Prime
sponsor there was significant discussion
about that we
participated uh those people
representing labor participated the
department was was at the table and we
came up with language that uh we we
meaning the Bia wouldn't have let the
charge on but it was something we could
live with we let everyone know we we can
live with this it raises uh weekly
benefit thresholds it increases that
maximum uh salary from 4 1 I think to 65
if I remember her language correctly it
did a lot of good things for uh
individuals who might find themselves
unemployed it also did it by the way in
a way that according to the Department's
evaluation could be implemented with
little to no risk that employers would
see a tax increase or the uh taxable
wage base which is currently at 14,000
being increase those are the two ways
that you bring more money into the trust
fund the the way it worked was they
increased the thresholds for discounts
now that's not the most desirable thing
from an employer perspective however uh
represent McKenzie correctly stated the
trust fund is is very rich right now and
even if you implemented uh the
provisions of senot 436 it would not
have an immediate impact on those
thresholds so the point is you could
have done this and employers at least in
the short term would feel no impact from
it the Senate chose not to move forward
with that bill I believe it was tabled
on a I think a 14 to 10
vote um so here we
are uh Senate Bill 330 passed that also
was a bill that uh we participated in
had some initial qualms over spent a
significant time with the department and
received in assurances and we have
confidence in the Department's ability
to be able to administer that if it
becomes law in a way that uh individuals
will not take advantage of it and in a
way that it will not negatively impact
employers my concern with the non-
gerine amendment is we're not early in
the session now we're late in the
session we do not have the time time or
the luxury to begin opening up
negotiations about what individual
parties can and cannot live with we have
what the language is and my
concern is twofold one I feel that will
have a negative impact on trust fund
balances and will have a negative impact
on
employers but more of more over than
that we already know what the Senate's
position is they were not willing to go
with with a bill
that we were okay
with they tabled that and my concern is
if this gets attached to 3:30 and goes
back across the um to the other chamber
I can see one of two things
happening the third thing which is they
would concur I don't see happening at
all I think they will either just non-c
Concur and the bill will be killed or
they will ask for a committee of
conference and demand that this Germain
language be
stripped um and if it's not they won't
uh sign a committee of conference report
and again the bill goes down so I'm
asking you um to preserve what what uh I
think everyone thought was was a bill
that was necessary to update language
relating to remote work which is what
330 is and save this discussion for for
another session I I assure you um Bia
will participate that in that and we
will participate in a way that
recognizes that there should be some
adjustment but the adjustments in this
amendment are too too fast and too high
for us be happy to answer any questions
thank you very much are there questions
yes representative
suent one of the differences between the
Senate bill and this amendment um is
that uh this amendment does not increase
the thresholds um which was a conscious
decision um in discussion in the interim
um because the thresholds have been
adjusted um fairly recently in such a
way that um frankly it likely is um uh
sufficient that we don't need to adjust
the thresholds again um therefore not
adjusting the thresholds actually I
think makes this more attractive than
the sen of version it may even bring the
a sen of version on board I I
respectfully disagree um and having
participated in every minute of the
Senate discussion I assure you that not
changing those thresholds will not
change uh Senators positions on on how
they voted on this issue I recognize
that that this language does not change
the thresholds I would say the
thresholds become irrelevant if if we
have a a economic slowdown or a
recession or God help us a severe
recession because we'll be well below
those thresholds so the discounts that
those are provided uh that positive
rated employers benefit from from those
thresholds won't matter because the
trust fund will be well below those
those uh established
limits uh Mr chairman thank you Mr ju is
your uh association's biggest concern
the um
individual increases for each level of
earned wages or is it that overall if
there is an economic downturn not as
severe asbe 2008 or and there um
pandemic that a um moderate
slowdown
will severely deplete the balance the in
in the event of a moderate
slowdown uh this bill will deplete the
balance far quicker than what the uh
proposed language in 436 was 436 did not
increase
um levels that are already set it added
new levels from 41 to 65 so the impact
would be far far less uh this one and
I'm sure if if he were asked the
department could testify this one would
cause a draw down far quicker
thank you further questions
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr J so the concern with
drawing down the trust fund balance uh
uh even if we don't get to the point
where we have to borrow money from the
federal government uh is that the
discounts will will will evaporate and
the the employers might pay as much as
$90 instead of the current $80 average
per a year
well it could potentially be a lot
higher than that if in addition to
losing the discounts there's an increase
in the taxable wage base or an increase
in the tax rate both of which happened
in the last uh severe recession in 2008
and both of which I might add Bia signed
on to because we recognized um how
severe the situation was and we also
recognized representative taking that
action at the state level allowed New
Hampshire to pay that money back to the
federal government with no interest
something virtually no other state was
able to do so we were willing to take on
some short-term pain for the long-term
gain thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony at this point I
have no other cards however uh everyone
who spoken has referred us to the um
Deputy Commissioner to answer some
questions I I don't know if you had a a
something you wanted to prepared to say
or you just want to go into
questions um I could address some of the
issues that have been brought up that
way hit some high points thank allow
since well I can do whatever you want me
to do since you control what happens
here I like your I like what you suggest
so go ahead uh Richard lers Deputy
Commissioner New Hampshire employment
security uh to address the issue of of
taxpaying employers versus reimbursing
employers so um New Hampshire uh
requires that the state as an employer
is a mandated reimbursal so the state
has to report quarterly employment but
it doesn't pay quarterly taxes so when a
state employee is separated and it's
determined they're eligible for
unemployment the state then reimburses
the trust fund dollar for dollar for the
benefits that are paid out local
employers so Municipal and County
um they have the option to be a
reimbursal or they can be treated as a
taxpayer the overwhelming majority of
them choose to be a reimbursing employer
about 90% of local and County employers
reimburse they do not pay taxes um and
then they they pay into the fund like
the state when they have a for when they
have an employee that's eligible uh
private nonprofits they also have a
choice they can be a reimbursal or they
can can be a taxpaying employer four
profit employers do not have a choice
they are mandated taxpaying employers so
they pay a quarterly tax that is based
on their experience or their risk to the
unemployment fund where we look at taxes
paid benefits paid out they have a rate
and they pay that rate on the first
$144,000 which is that taxable wage base
that you've heard mentioned they pay
that on the first 14 to each employee uh
for the year
so when you look at overall employment
levels I just did a quick math and
looking at our most recent quarterly
reports from employers so this is New
Hampshire reported employment State
Employment is a little under 3% of total
employment and local employment is a
little under
7% of total employment in the State uh
when we did uh when we were talking with
the subcommittee about um an impact on
the state as an employer um the
state looking at calendar year
2023 uh the state was charged uh just
over
$142,000 in re in reimbursements that
they had to pay to the unemployment fund
if that were increased um by say the the
amount of the the Senate Bill the
amended Senate bill that would have been
another 30
$7,000 it' be slightly higher um with
the amended house bill cuz the amended
house bill which is being amended here
in desc Senate Bill 330 had had slightly
higher
impact uh so those were were those uh
numbers with regard to the impact on the
trust fund that we've talked about so we
did I see some of you looking at the the
charts that were reviewed um uh a while
back when the committee had that hearing
so we did stress test the fund we did
look to see what the impact on the trust
fund both um at the the in the current
climate right now um with a strong
economy and we also looked at a moderate
and severe recession scenarios to see
what all of the bills would do and when
we did that with um the amended version
of House Bill 1522 which was a uh
significantly reduced uh cost from the
original House Bill 1522 when we looked
at that the increase in projected
benefit payments when we when we looked
at actual benefit payments in 2023 would
be that if this Bill had been in effect
it would have been a 33% in total
payments going out um that was about an
$8.5 million increase so going from 26
million in actual payments to if this
Bill had been in effect it would have
been 34.5 million in actual payments
trust fund right now is at $400
million um when we projected that out
through the end of our forecasted period
which goes out through the end of
2025 we project the trust fund right now
would be at 393 million um at the end of
2025 without anything being done if this
bill were to go into effect it'd be
about $40 million lower or just over
$350 million
when we look at a modest recession so
something similar to the early 2000s
where unemployment goes from you know
right now we're at 2.6% but unemployment
gets up to
45% um you'd be looking
at
um without any changes the trust fund
would be just under $340 million and if
1522 is amended were in effect you'd be
looking at about
$265 million so about a little over a
$60 million impact in a modest recession
so three just under 340 current state
265 with this bill in
effect if we looked at a Great Recession
scenario so New Hampshire sustaining
unemployment at about
62% uh like we did uh with the 2008 2009
Great Recession
uh we project that the trust fund would
go down without any changes the trust
fund would be would go down to 162
million if this bill were in effect we
would we um forecast that the fund would
go uh to just over $106
million so um there you're looking at
about another um you know 55 million in
um additional dispersements benefits
going out so that so that's the stress
testing that we did um in um either
scenario either doing nothing or House
Bill
1522 um as long as the downturn
behaved consistently with one of these
models which it should we looked we used
actual recessions actual economic uh
conditions that New Hampshire has
experienced in the past the trust fund
would not run out of money um um so um
that's the the the testing that we had
done and um just looking at the the the
amendment um again the amendment does
not do anything to the bottom 17
existing benefit amounts those stay the
same that wage replacement rate is right
around 58 to
60% so someone collecting in those
bottom tier um earning levels is going
to going to get about 58% of their wages
replaced by their unemployment benefit
the next 35 of the existing tiers
because we have 52 existing tiers that
are in statute the next 35 would be
increased with this proposal and then
the proposal would uh Implement 19 new
tiers over 3 years so 19 additional
tiers it would bring the maximum weekly
benefit
up from currently at
$427 a week which is where it's been
since
2007 um that right now if you earn
$41,500 in your four quarter base period
that's what you qualify for
$427 a week about a 54% wage replacement
if you earn $755,000 right now you still
get
$427 a week so the average private
sector wage earner right now if they
were to lose their job unexpectedly in
need unemployment they'd be looking at a
wage replacement rate of about
30% so we're replacing 30% of their
earnings from what they had earned um
the new top tier would be
672 um that would be payable to someone
earning I think we're over
$60,000 um or at
$60,000 and that wage replacement rate
is is about
58% so the new proposed tiers maintain a
wage replacement rate of about
58% the difference between that and the
Senate amended Bill the Senate amended
Bill maintained a wage replacement rate
for those upper tiers of
54% so that was the the main difference
and the reason why there's a difference
in cost uh between the two but I'll I'll
stop there and I'll allow uh the
committee to do what it is the committee
wants to do all right thank you very
much
um representative kahill a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
labors uh do you have any way of looking
at the economic impacts that these
increases would be for our economy to
the people who currently getting 427
then getting this bump and and their
Wakely
benefits um well it so that so that that
average person coming in right now is
getting uh three out of every $10
replaced right so this would increase
that um to slightly higher we do know
that unemployment benefits are not uh
dollars that are saved they are dollars
that are spent uh they are dollars that
are spent in our local communities and
it does allow um uh people to avoid
needing to to depend on their local
municipalities for support during an
econ an unexpected economic hardship uh
so we know those dollars are spent right
away during the pandemic we paid out uh
just over $2 billion
that went right into the New Hampshire
economy thank you are there further
questions representative
Sullivan you said that under the current
um setup um the average um benefit is
30% um that's covering everything from
the the lowest earner to the highest
earner who's unemployed um what would
the average be with under the amendment
because you said it's 58% at 60,000 but
you didn't mention the average rate
yeah so that was when we when we looked
at the average private sector wage
earner based on actual employer reports
that's where those those numbers came
from so right now when that um
individual comes in and there in the mid
to Upper 60s uh in terms of annual
earnings um they they receive right now
about a 30% wage replacement with that
427 uh this proposed bill um have having
uh six what did we
say
672 if you earned
$60,000 in your base period so now
you're up you're closer uh to that mid
50s to uh you know 55% wage replacement
rather than being in the
30s if you are a $60,000 wage earner and
you're getting 672 your wage replacement
rate is
58% follow up um
so so the um the average is very close
to the 58,000 or I'm sorry 58% correct
it'd be it'd be slightly under that
because that average earner is a little
bit higher than what the the proposed
Max tier would be here and and there are
some people who are earning over 60,000
who um are capped at the 60,000 rate
correct so if you come in if you earned
uh
$500,000 you're still capped at whatever
that Max weekly Ben benit amount is
right now that's 427 thank
you further questions yes representative
stop thank you um one of the concerns
that was just expressed um was that if
we had a major recession we would need
to borrow money um from the federal
government in order to refill the
coffers and and pay out unemployment if
we do nothing um in a severe recession
would we still have to do
that if Brian gotab were here our our
state Economist he would not answer your
question um what I can tell you is what
we have experienced right so during the
Great Recession New Hampshire did need
to borrow in order to pay unemployment
benefits we borrowed twice each time we
borrowed about $60
million um the legislature responded and
uh both business and workers came in
made sacrifices and that was quickly
repaid as Mr juv had mentioned New
Hampshire avoided all borrowing costs
that was free money uh for New Hampshire
and then our our trust fund quickly uh
rebounded after that what we're looking
at right now when we stress test uh the
fund for this bill we look at that
experience we don't look at some other
hypothetical recession we look at the
actual experience from both a mild and
severe recession and in both of those
situations the trust fund would continue
to be able to pay benefits without
borrowing however the next economic
downturn could be quite different than
either of those but that's the best we
can do with the existing information
okay thank you further
questions representative kahill thank
you again Mr chair and thank you again
Mr labors when you said free money it
just kind of triggered a recent memory
for me
and actually those are the best ones um
wasn't there 14 million in arpa money
that was used to bulk up the uh trust
fund to give those discounts a little
sooner that free
money um there was 109 million um and
free money is never free right that's a
bad bad expression that I used um the
trust fund was the beneficiary of $109
million over the course of the pandemic
in unused but previous L obligated cares
act money and that was a decision from
the governor um where rather than
allowing that money to go back to
Washington DC he decided that we're
going to try to use it in these programs
of need but when those programs of need
do not use all of the obligated money
rather than losing that money let's have
it go somewhere where it stays in New
Hampshire and the decision was that it
will go into the unemployment trust fund
so when we talk about the trust fund
being at 400 million right now 109 of
that came in as a result of unused
obligated cares act dollars to prevent
them from going back to uh the federal
government thank you and thank you for
that question I I never had it so
succinctly explained I Now understand
what that means further
questions representative Alani thank you
Mr chairman and Deputy Commissioner lers
it's always good to have you here with
us
um can you speak to if this amendment
goes through goes through the house
um during the 2008 recession would there
be more positive employers paying a
penalty longer than than during that
time um I'll try to answer it and if I'm
going in the wrong direction you tell me
that's not what you meant but you
buttered me up by saying that you liked
having me here so
um
so the changes that were made to the the
statutory changes that were made a few
budget Cycles ago with the the solvency
controls in state law the
um thresholds were changed so the fund
balance reduction thresholds when
employers get a reduction to their rate
when the fund is achieving um
important balance Milestones where the
the pressure can be reduced on employers
because the fund does not need more
Revenue because it's gotten to a point
where it is solvent those were increased
except for the first level so for the
last decade the first level of the
balance in the trust fund where
employers have received a reduction has
always been $250 million that goes back
to the the changes made by the
legislature um in the LA in the Great
Recession that was not changed so
employers right now still get a half
Point reduction to their rate and um to
think about the importance of a half
point when a new employer comes in at
2.7% if you're to take 0.5 off that's a
significant reduction um so it's still
at $250 million right now the employers
get a 1% reduction when the trust fund
achieves a $350 million balance for an
entire quarter that's where they are
right now they're getting a 1% reduction
and if the fund maintains a balance of
400 million for an entire quarter every
day of that quarter they get a 1 and a
half%
reduction the most significant change
made um with the solvency controls in my
mind was not the increase to the top two
balance thresholds bringing those up to
350 and 400 million to allow the fund to
achieve true solvency which is where it
is at right now I think the more
significant change was the elimination
of the search charges that kicked in on
employers when they could least afford
to pay it so prior to those changes when
the trust funds started to drop there
were two half Point SE charges so an
employer would not only lose their fund
balance reductions but then they would
actually get hit with sear charges on
their rate a uh 0 five was the
discretionary to the commissioner and
the other 0.5 was mandated if the fund
fell below $150 million those were both
eliminated and the theory behind that
was that if we allow the fund to grow to
a true point of solvency during a time
when the economy is growing when
employment is growing and employers can
afford to pay it then we don't need to
have that additional SE charge hitting
employers when they can when they can
least afford to pay it in a downturn so
right now you you as the fund is
depleted because benefit payments are
going up unemployment is up um the your
the the um experience of the employer is
a gradual or maybe an all of a sudden
loss in the fund balance reduction so
rather than getting that 1% uh reduction
you're back to your true experienced
rate however you do not have any sirar
charges right now those have been
eliminated from St
statute follow follow um and for
positive rated employeers and negative
rated employers would an increase like
this tip more from the positive into a
negative rating which could affect their
payments so any anytime it's a it's a
very good point because anytime you're
increasing the amount of benefit
payments that are going
out it will have some level of impact on
employers because of the way that their
rates are set for un employment uh tax
purposes because this is this is an
insurance program it's it's risk-based
so we evaluate the risk of the employer
to the trust fund and when we say risk
we mean what is the likelihood that
you're going to cause dollars to be your
employment decisions or economic
conditions um is going to result in your
employees being unemployed and needing
to draw down from the unemployment trust
fund so when you increase the amount of
benefits being paid out per week to an
individual ual that is going to then
impact the experience of the employer if
they're not laying very many people off
it will be a small impact but if they
have are having regular impacts or unex
or regular layoffs or or um unexpected
layoffs due to whatever reason it will
result in higher benefit charges to
their experience now they might be
sufficiently positive rated meaning that
over the entire history of that employer
being an employer in New Hampshire
because we look all the way back to when
the employer first started and
registered in the state as an employer
if they are are close to the line
meaning that their total taxes paid in
are close to what the total benefits are
that have been paid out where that that
could tip them from going positive to
negative that would cause an increase in
rates so the the lowest rates are
reserved for those that cost the trust
fund the less the least amount right so
you're in the most advantageous tax
table which is in statute if you are not
causing um a high benefit payments to
the trust fund if you're
uh recently positive rated but have some
sort of event that causes a significant
amount of unemployment um and you become
negative rated you go into our middle
table which is for those employers that
have been negative rated for less than 4
years and if you are chronically
negative rated um you know you have a
seasonal pattern to your Employments
you're laying people off every year
those employers are the the biggest um
cost to the trust fund they pay the
highest rate and they pay at the the
third table which has the highest rates
and can be up to Mid seven I think we're
at 7 and 1 12%
if you're negative rated you don't get
those fund balance reductions either um
you get an you get an inverse search
charge so as the fund Falls your a
negative rated employer sees their SE
charge go up and as the fund increases
they see their negative rated Sur charge
go down so that's kind of the
distinction between positive and
negative uh rated employers and how they
we try to assess that risk by the amount
that they're required to pay in thank
you Mr chairman a final question if I
may um when you looked at the benefit
amounts and the time that people spent
on unemployment do you see an increase
in the time spent on unemployment given
the fact that it's moving to
58% um well well I think the existence
of unemployment benefits increases the
length of unemployment but it but it's
it's supposed to right it's supposed to
provide a stabilizing Force to allow
that individual to go to a job hopefully
somewhat com comparable to what they
were doing rather than being in a a
situation of desperation so just the
existing existence of unemployment
benefits increase the length of
unemployment right now New Hampshire
we're we're right around average
duration of 10 10 to 11 weeks um it has
um increased slightly over the last few
months but still significantly below
where we were in 2019 which by all
measures was a strong economy um so I
would I would expect that there there
could be um some level of impact
increasing duration um obviously when we
stress test the fund with this bill that
is increased duration because we're
modeling it after those those recession
scenarios which has a higher number of
average weeks uh that people file for
but overall New Hampshire has uh one of
the lowest um average durations um in
the country so 101 weeks um despite 26
being available um and anytime you
increase benefits there could
potentially be a a slight increase um to
the length of time of filing but again
we're looking at you know rather than uh
54 % wage replacement going up to 58%
I'm not sure how um noticeable that
would be in terms of increasing duration
thank you thank you Mr chairman
representative kahill again Mr Shar and
thank you again Mr labors when an
employer uh lays off someone and pays
them their unearned uh their unused
vacation time that's a that's a positive
for the trust fund isn't
it as so they delay maybe even there's
no need in a strong economy like we have
they don't even have to even have to
claim a weat do they um well so it it is
counted against their eligibility right
so if you're earning $1,000 a week and
part of your you you unfortunately lose
your job and you're paid $5,000 for
whatever reason is that is going to
delay your eligibility for unemployment
by 5 weeks um so it doesn't reduce the
number of weeks you're eligible for you
could still file for 26
um but you're not going to be eligible
until that that separation payment is
exhausted followup and this in turn
benefits the trust fund that we so
dearly want to want to
protect it is in all of our interest to
protect the trust fund uh very much so
employers and workers um and yes that um
because of the strong economy um there
uh is strong demand for jobs across all
Industries right now if an employer is
providing some sort of Separation
payment that is going to have a positive
impact on the trust fund because there
will be fewer dollars that are being
paid out yes thank you Mr L any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for all your oh we do have uh
representative buar thank you Mr chair
and thank you Deputy Commissioner labors
as you as always you've uh
been able to saturate my brain with your
testimony and I appreciate
it uh so thank you for your testimony as
I said I I have no further cards I do
see we have our representative from the
County Association and there since a
number of people mentioned the impact on
the counties there might be a question
uh so if you wouldn't mind uh stepping
forward and and
send us a card too yeah well you can
after you're done you can fill out a
card yeah I will fill out a pin card
after uh I finish uh Kate Horan New
Hampshire Association of counties um the
association is opposed to the amendment
um particularly for those smaller
counties while a 20 to 30% potential
increase for hillsbor and Rockingham can
they probably absorb that yeah can Coos
and Sol
that's probably going to be a more
significant impact on their budget um
particularly um I don't know what the
unemployment rates are for the county so
I apologize for not having that
information with you but um if it is a
significant increase to those smaller
counties that means likely an increase
in uh County taxes but I'm happy to try
and answer any questions that folks have
so are there questions representative
kale
and thank you Miss Morgan is is it
generally safe to assume that you know
in your experience and your observations
that layoffs at the county level are
rare even in those aforementioned
counties um there a challenging question
to answer representative kahill and I do
know some counties have eliminated
certain positions over the years and
people have either chosen to stay or not
stay but I don't have any historical
data for you today I
apologize thank you I will I would like
to follow up on that question um Deputy
Commissioner labers mentioned a number
of 7% of the total unemployment is
Municipal and County uh just based on
what you know does that seem County
probably equally balanced probably yes
okay thank
you any further
questions seeing none
I appreciate you coming
up and with that that was all the cards
we had if there is no one else uh who
has offered to testify then we will
close the hearing on this amendment and
in five minutes we have scheduled our
executive session on this bill and on
one
other and the chairman has called for a
caucus of Republicans across the
hall thank you
everyone
e e
thank
you
oh
e
e e
will come to order
please I have to wait for one person to
fill their water bottle cuz I can't
start without we stole it you can't have
it what the folder I need that thank you
sir let me do
this opening the executive setion on
Senate Bill 517
recognized representative brudy thank
you Mr chairman I want to apologize to
everybody for being late we had a little
problem this morning but we made it and
thank you all for hanging in thank you
appreciate that um recognize
representative seaworth for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I'd make a motion
of itl the motion on the floor on Senate
Bill 517 oh second is uh
in this we to legislate has been
seconded by representative
Sullivan representative seaworth you are
recognized to speak to your motion uh
thank you very much as uh most of you
know we had a subcommittee meet on this
bill um my personal goal in that
subcommittee was to figure out what we
could all agree on um there's certainly
issues to debate on this bill and but I
wanted us to come away and agree ment
and uh one thing we could all agree on
in the subcommittee is that if you look
at the history of this bill when this
language was submitted to the Senate at
the same time and just to be clear for
everyone who's walked in this is a bill
that deals with the position of raas um
in Residence Halls at universities and
the bill was suggesting changing the
definition of
employment um so when that language was
put in on the Senate side the uh
representatives from the universities
that were in here in our meetings were
also working with the Department of
Labor and as that part of that process
the department made a revision to their
rules um in the October December time
frame at the end of last year and as far
as I can tell they corrected the problem
that existed and as far as I can tell
there is no other outstanding
issue um that the rules will not address
properly so it has been uh we've said a
number of times in this committee that
if the department can handle something
uh there is no need for us to intervene
by changing legislation and this is a
complicated enough issue that I think if
we start changing rsas and changing
definitions we could easily have some
unintended consequences so the
recommendation of the subcommittee and
my motion is that we itl this bill we
let the rules take their course and if
sometime in the future we realize that
things still aren't working we can put
in new legislation to address that thank
you Solin thank you m Mr Mr
Speaker not happy Mr
chair um
like he said first of all um and I would
just also point out that this um bill as
presented initially presented it changed
um six different statutes uh to remove
workers rights um in New Hampshire
rsas um it became apparent that that um
actually wasn't necessary because the
unemployment law already made that
exception so the sixth one was stripped
out left five um but the bottom line is
that's way more than could possibly be
necessary in the first place and
secondly as um representative seaworth
said uh we have a rules change that we
believe is going to address the um the
issue it's going to allow um colleges
that have concerns about minimum wage or
tracking hours or anything like that to
apply for a a
waiver with that waiver um their um
issues would be resolved um so um
there's really no need to go changing
statutes stripping rights um there's a
Avenue just like with the unemployment
that's already taken care of we believe
that the uh rules change that the um
Department of Labor have um undertaken
um take care of that department and it
also became apparent that the um uh
employment status of um these resident
Halls advisers um is viewed differently
by um different Federal um departments
as well as by um potentially uh State
entities so um
it it's going to probably have to work
its way out over time but we believe
that the issue at hand has been
addressed so um I agree with the U um uh
motion of itl and ask everyone to
support that
any other
comments the chair has just two quick
ones
um uh the the chairman Vice chairman I
received a a memo and I will make sure
everyone gets it I thought everyone did
get it it was a list of every single
University and college in the state and
it had different columns in it and the
columns had who gets uh stien who gets
free room who gets free board who gets
both or whatever and it was a a
a mishmash of different things about who
got
what anything that we change is going to
cause harm to
another if we fix one for one University
or one college it it's going to be
detrimental to the other that's my first
point my second point is I like laws
versus
rules um so I would like to see a new
bill come next year but it has to take
into account all the different
circumstances there are other parts of
the law that we have
uh that some of you may remember from
your tenure here ski
instructors they don't get paid but they
get free skiing you know there's other
mechanisms that are in our law where it
this could be addressed so um hopefully
that will will occur next year uh but I
agree with the in expenditure legislate
motion are there any other
comments Madam
clerk I'll just add it's kind of awesome
that we all agree on this that's nice um
it's also Complicated by the fact that
when these positions were developed and
before they evolved to be so much
differently um part of what they gain
given how expensive it is to go to
college in New Hampshire we have the
highest state tuition in in the country
too for so it's about even at our state
schools um the value for what Ras get
depending on which part of of the
package they get for what they do is
really complicated and and so much
different now because of the cost of
college and all the related expenses so
that's another caveat Madam clerk would
it surprise you that I was an R
yes uh before we take a vote we need to
make some um introductions we have some
uh people that are filling in today uh
representative seore is is uh filling in
for resentative Prout representative
Smith for representative Del s
u d Linda D sylvestro and representative
Veil for representative l cler d Simone
representative D Simone what did I
say I'm
sorry does that say Simone it does sorry
my my apologies BL from the table
[Laughter]
I deserve that one so are we all ready
for a vote the motion on the floor is to
legislate been moved second we've had
our discussion um no additional comments
Madam clerk please call the role Vice
chair seaworth yes rep avalani yes rep D
Simon yes rep love yes rep
Boyd
absent representative Boyd yes he is I
missed that I'm
sorry uh representative Mason yes rep K
yes rep drgo yes rep Granger yes ranking
Dem Sullivan yes rep barudi yes rep
Cahill yes representative Smith yes rep
Susi yes rep bushard yes R McKenzie yes
the clerk votes yes R Bale
yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes that is 19
y0 there any objection to consent
agenda did you call girl that
representative
Bry um okay representative Smith um
thank you um Mr chair I have noticed in
the room there are a number of people
who are clearly guests of the house and
I wonder if you might want to find out
why who they are or why they're here and
welcome
them I'm pretty familiar with any most
everyone here but yes I do see some some
I do see some guests uh please if you're
if you're willing uh let let me make
finish my motion oh I'm sorry I thought
you did no is there any objection to
consent agenda seeing none It Go on the
consent agenda uh if any guest would
like to introduce yourself please feel
free to stand or sit and introduce
yourselves oh
nice well thank you very much for uh
joining the house labor committee and
our executive session thank
you I sent that table to the whole
Committee in you announce it uh just uh
will had mentioned a table that how
different universities treated the ra
positions differently that was a
document that was supplied to the
subcommittee um I just sent a scan of
that to the house labor um group so if
anyone was one wondering what that was
look in your email and you should see it
thank you I will add that it doesn't
include Dartmouth because the
organization that put that together has
the Consortium of every actually I think
it's three un I forget the other two
Thomas Moore is there a Thomas Moore
college and there's the third one that's
not on there because they're not in that
Consortium so but otherwise it's pretty
good our final bill for the session on
Executive session is Senate Bill 330
FN I like like recognize representative
Sullivan for a
motion I move to adopt um Amendment 2024
18658 the amendment has been moved I
have a second please second from represa
Susi you recognized to speak to your
motion thank you
these are strange times that we live in
um I think we've got an amendment here
that excuse me addresses an issue that I
believe many of us on both sides feels
is in need of being addressed um the
um the bottom line is that um we did
speak with the clerk out in the hallway
and the clerk has um told us that the um
the speaker will rule this amendment out
of order um I'm moving it I'm asking
people to vote for it simply so we can
send a message um to the world that we
think this is is an issue that's um in
need of being
addressed so um um unemployment table
has not changed since
2007 that's way too long we have a very
low maximum benefit
um that could be addressed by um adding
levels to that table and um both a
Senate bill that U uh did not pass as
well as the um um bill that
representative McKenzie proposed now
sits on the
table both of those address that in
slightly different ways this amendment
is um identical to representative
McKenzie's original bill um and while it
will not result in um the change that we
would like um I just believe it's
important to shed light on this so that
uh going
forward um it'll be viewed as important
and something that we need to work on
early and effectively for the next uh
session um we also believe that the
underlying bill is a good bill perhaps
not as important as the amendment but
the amendment's not going to happen um
and we want to make sure the underlying
Bill does happen so um my my motion is
to adopt the amendment and um I ask
people to support it to send a message
that improving the uh benefit table for
unemployment is uh is an important thing
thank you representative seaworth I find
myself in an odd position I think I'm
going to agree with every single thing
that my fellow representative just said
except that I'm going to vote the
opposite of of how he asked me to and
the reason is exactly what he explained
I think it's very important knowing
what's going to happen to this bill when
it hits the floor that we have a um if
this is assuming this is going to be the
majority P report ought to pass with
Amendment we need a Minority Report that
explains why uh when there's an issue
with that we're going to go with a to
pass because I think we have a consensus
around this table that the underlying
bill is also a good bill and and that
we whatever happens with the amendment
we want to see that other language uh
move forward so I am going to vote
against um the motion to amend and the
motion if that passes the motion that
follows and I will be writing a Minority
Report um to pass uh Senate Bill 330 as
sent To Us by the Senate I expect to get
over it
representative
McKenzie uh first of all let me uh just
Express um how much I appreciate the
efforts of the Department of Employment
Security uh and to all the colleagues on
this committee who some of whom have
never been uh have any um relationship
or understanding uh of how the
unemployment system works so I hope that
this legislation provided some insight
into that uh
um that said I I would agree uh that
something is going to need to be done
2007 was last time you uh you got this
through got some things through uh but I
also you know for all those people uh
who were in this house uh for the
hundreds of people who were distributed
all throughout the state of New
Hampshire uh at some point there's going
to be a layoff in in your
community and you're going to to look
people in the eye and when they ask you
so what is the unemployment benefit I'm
going to
receive and you're going to have to be
honest with the metalit the same
benefits you would have received back in
2007 and I don't think that is a
defendable position uh and I think it's
unfortunate for workers who depend on
the unemployment system in some of the
worst times of their lives so uh so I
I I understand where we're at in terms
of the environment that we're in and the
the what we're up against but I do think
that that uh this is a valuable um
exercise that the discussion that we
went through is valuable and there was
$400 million in the unemployment trust
fund so most money I've ever seen in the
unemployment trust fund quite frankly in
all the years I've been doing this so
we're in pretty good position and I just
want to say one thing the system is not
going to go broke it's not going to go
bankrupt as might have been suggested if
this legislation would have pass my hope
would be that I would uh if this does
not Prevail uh that I will start work on
it again and if I'm lucky enough to be
uh elected and fortunate enough to be
back here that that uh we will start
this process all over again thank you Mr
chair
welcome thank you Mr chair so there's a
lot of ISM of how the current
unemployment system works and it seems
to me that the unemployment insurance
industry is a strange one in that it's
monopolized all the problems that we are
currently experiencing and all the
desires that we have to improve the
unemployment system wouldn't be
necessary if we had a private sector
unemployment system like almost every
other insurance system scheme out there
uh the idea that the government needs to
monopolize the insurance industry for
unemployment I find to be absurd I do
not think that the government should be
involved in the unemployment industry
whatsoever thank you
thank
you represent schs Madam chair clerk
I'll take all those um I just want to
add that I know some folks had expressed
a concern oh if will this uh encourage
people to stay on unemployment longer
and having been unemployed and having
been on New Hampshire uh unemployment
myself um once when I was laid off um I
will say that it's still under the rate
of pay that you made when you were
working so the best incentive of all is
that hardworking people who have earned
the right to receive
unemployment uh are eager to get back to
work and I know that firsthand there's
nothing about being unemployed is that
is
encouraging you know um and I hope you
don't experience that but if you have
you'll know that there's every incentive
uh inside
oneself uh to get a job and be off of
unemployment I say with all authority
thank you thank
you the unemployment system is um an
amazing safety net for both the employee
and
Society because it allows it individual
to have some replacement of their income
to not place the burden on on the the
rest of the government or or what have
you and well it may be a monopolistic
thing and it may be one of these uh
things that some people think is kind of
socialized um it has
worked and and and uh it's worked for
many friends of mine who called me
during the pandemic and were complaining
why is the compensation so low and why
is it max out at um the $440,000 mark
and what have
you we do have $400 million almost 395
whatever amongst friends million dollars
it doesn't pass a smell test that we're
sitting on that kind of money and we
can't make some changes since
2007 for those who maybe question what
representative Sullivan said about why
it's not going to pass is because it is
a f note and putting a fiscal note on a
bill that comes over from the Senate
that's not a fiscal note would need a
suspension of the rules which would be
2/3 we all know we're not going to get
that okay so um this is where for the
kids in from conquered High School this
is where politics comes in how do you
make a
point that something needs to be done
that this may not be the right way to do
it um but at least making a point from
the
committee at the same time it is
inappropriate for a committee to pass
something
that we know is going to be uh ruled in
you know in a prop improper or whatever
by the
speaker so we play politics which is
fine minority leader and I have
agreed uh coincidentally we have a 10 N
Split here between individual ual
between the party there have 10
Democrats and nine
Republicans so the the motion can pass
we know in the full
floor uh the amendment uh will be ruled
in appropriate and then we have the
original 330 Senate Bill 330 coming over
from the Senate which I think everyone
is in agreement with or a vast majority
of agreement
with so unless I've gotten it wrong
representative Sullivan we're going to
play a little bit of what we want to do
in utilizing Parliament procedure to get
what we would like to have said and done
um to the best of all possibilities
here I would also say that I I would not
make a motion to overrule the chair with
regard with regard to the uh rejection
of the amendment I'm not I don't want to
waste the time of the uh um the house um
I simply want to see this amendment go
to the floor
and um meet its demise as is necessary
so while I do support uh the the uh goal
of the I do support the underlying bill
I do support the goal of the amendment
it's inappropriate as chairman to uh
send something to my speaker that I know
he's going to find Germain so I will be
vot voting against it um support of the
concept and I think we all know how the
vote's going to come out so does
everyone understand the circumstances
okay so a motion on the floor is ought
to pass or the
amendment adopting
Amendment 1865 H okay and has been moved
in second we've had discussion uh all in
favor say I oppose say no oh I'm sorry
did you all right all oppose say no
madame clerk please call the
role um Vice chair seaworth no rep Balan
no rep D Simon no rep love
no rep Bo is not here right I did not
scratch his name sorry uh R Mason no rep
kcam no excuse Draco no R Greener no
ranking Dam Sullivan yes rep barudi yes
rep kahill yes rep Smith yes RIP Susi
yes R buard yes R McKenzie yes the clerk
votes yes uh rep Vil yes rep stab
yes Mr chair
no that is 10 Y and nine Nays uh the
amendment passes representative Sullivan
you recognized for a
motion I move ought to pass with
Amendment motion is ought to pass with
amendment seconded by representative
Susi you recognized to speak to your
motion the um the underlying Bill s SP
330 um is a good bill that's that is
going to save people from being denied
unemployment benefits um that was the
testimony we heard that essentially
people got caught in a trap with regard
to their um um the types of employment
they were they were seeking and uh
this will allow in this new environment
we're living in with homework being um
far more common that if someone is
exploring um working from home as a
replacement for their um uh former
employment that that would not
automatically uh cause them to be denied
um unemployment benefits so I think it's
it's a good bill solves the problem and
um uh I hope we can all support it for
it to go forward
thank you Mr chairman uh I concur with
that I I would also say that when I
first saw this language come over from
the Senate I was a little nervous about
it um the chairman just gave us some
information on the last bill that a lot
of times we don't like to push things to
rules we like to see the statute lay out
um what the Department's going to
enforce and so I initially had some uh
nervousness about this but hearing the
details of it I now feel comfortable
the right now if you look at what the
way the law is written if someone fills
out an application for unemployment and
they're asked are you available to work
outside the home and they check no it
doesn't matter why they could have the
best reason in the world and the law
says that the department must must deny
them unemployment and really that's what
we're fixing if you're eligible for
unemployment or let's say potentially
eligible eligible the department will
figure that out and work the details and
they're they're used to doing that they
have rules that do that they have people
that do that and what this bill in
essence really does is allows them to
use that
expertise um to deal with a situation
where someone is looking for uh work
from home employment and on that now
that I understand that I completely
support this Bill thank
you I'm going to support the the bill
only because I cannot um support this
because I uh if all goes as we expect it
will I cannot stand up on the floor and
support 3:30 if I'm voting against
it right now if we if the underlying
Bill if the amendment fails
right just wanted everyone to know why
I'm going to be voting the way I am it
would be hypocritical for me to to not
um support the final bill even though I
don't agree with the amendment and then
if it comes to the floor and people say
well what are you guys doing what what
does all this mean I can at least stand
and say yes we support the underlying
bill so I just want everyone to know
what I will be
doing any other comments
seeing none motion of ought to pass of
the amendment has been moved in seconded
we've had a discussion Madam clerk
please call the rooll if you're in favor
you'll be voting yes oppose you'll
voting
no Vice chair seaworth
no rep
avalani
no rep D
Simone
no rep love no
rep Mason
no rep
culcom
no rep drgo no rep Granger
no ranking Dem Sullivan yes rep barudi
yes rep Cahill yes rep Smith yes rep
Susi yes rep Bard yes rep McKenzie yes
the clerk votes yes re Bale yes rep stab
yes Mr chair yes that is 10 yay and nine
nay 11
voted him oh my gosh sorry you know I
really am listening sorry about
that that's all right I
call size yeah you know we're doing our
best we're in it for the
money um I would um the clerk has pushed
me if you could get the um your blurb to
me today um or at
least while we're watching the Bruins
tonight um it would be nice and I'll get
it to Jamie
tomorrow is there any other business
coming forth this committee
if I could in the spirit of U of what
the speaker referred to as the month of
to recognize uh employees of the state
and the contribution that they make I
would like to
recognize uh the people who staffed this
committee uh and uh thank them for all
the work that they do to make the wheels
turn and we greatly appreciate what
you're
do thank you Mark representative
Sullivan you and I had discussed
uh a
lunch we have a couple more weeks we
will get back to you in one of our
breaks if if if we can try to go ahead
basically a lot of the Committees um get
together at the end of the session and
have a um a a lunch a communal lunch
with the entire committee um we thought
it would be important to uh get get our
business done so that no one will accuse
us of having um secret conversations
about uh bills um but um uh I thought we
might do it on the last day but um I've
got a grandbaby at home and I'm getting
over a cold so I don't not not a good
date today but if we can find a date uh
that would work for folks um I think it
would be a great thing because um as has
been said um the labor committee is the
best committee so we should celebrate
that
any other business in front of this
committee real quick who is doing the
Minority Report on
3:30
e
e e